Low frequency sounds of
the sort that your voice is
that late night FM DJ
voice are responded to
in the brain by neurons,
no surprise there,
but the frequency that those neurons fire
is also low frequency.
In other words, when you
speak in your low voice.
Right.
The other person's brain hears that
and starts firing in a low frequency tone.
In other words, it entrains to your voice,
not just the timing, but it's actually
like you're essentially
playing an emotional piano down
in the low keys of their--
Oh, right.
Of their mind.
Now, when you go up to
the high frequencies,
the neurons can't follow
that high frequency.
So there's something special
about low frequency sound
that actually changes the emotional tone
of the people that hear
that low frequency sound.